okay let's see who's next here let's go
to the 7/7 four area code who's calling
774 could be a local viewer you know you
never know who's calling in from 774
today
hey David this is cliff I'm from what's
there hey cliff what's going on hey
nothing how are you good
so I was just wondering I've been
watching a lot of anger danger yang yep
and so I was just wondering what what's
your take do you think that socialism
makes people more sociable I think
that's a very very silly question well
I'm just wondering just because in in
general you you got all the money out
there and then more people you know they
can talk they can exchange
uh-huh the socialism make people more
social that's the question yes and what
does that have to do with Andrew yang um
well you know he's always accused of
being a socialist but really I was huge
and of being a socialist I've seen him
would be accused of being a libertarian
yeah I mean I mean yeah
people not to say uneducated people but
people just their first their first
assumption of him is generally you know
he's always attacked as a socialist I've
not seen that once like who's an example
of a person who did that oh you haven't
all right well I mean when he was I
think it was Fox News I don't remember
the exact name of the anchor but I know
one of them said and I know he directly
said he said come on you're smarter than
that you don't you know that this isn't
socialism hmm okay yeah maybe that was
like Stuart Varney or Neil Cavuto or
something like that when yang talked
about you bi listen I think that
absolutely socialism makes people much
more social and it would just improve
everybody's dating and and personal
lives and friendships I think that's a
really really insightful question okay
thank you very all right very very good
thank you
okay let's go to our next caller